you know what's going on over in San  Francisco which is a leftist and I think  you could argue globalist it is you it  is a city that is a centralized  one-party city that has all the power to  a couple people the foolish governor of  San Francisco uh the foolish mayor of  San Francisco and then the clownish  governor of California uh well you know  what's going on in San Francisco besides  all the drugs I know you know about the  drugs besides all the homelessness the  General State of Decay uh the impending  zombie apocalypse and all that I know  you know about all that stuff uh they're  proposing  let's show the headline this is a good  one San Francisco's reparations  committee proposes 5 million dollars to  each black long-time resident and total  debt forgiveness  I would just like to say that I now  identify as a black chick from San  Francisco a long time black chick from  San Francisco okay I am Shaniqua from  San Francisco  [Music]  thank you  foreign  [Music]